[Music]
I think we've already had this it's like
you you walk around and you young and
then one day you realize that you're not
young you you sexy and then you realize
actually no one's even looking at you
anymore you you nag your children to
clean their room and one day there's
silence where their child once was you
healthy until you get a diagnosis that
brings you to your knees and really the
reality of life is that tough emotions
are part of our contract with life like
we we don't get to have a meaningful
career or as a family or leave the world
a better place without stress and
discomfort and yet we live in a culture
that pays lip service to like going
towards your you know going out of your
comfort zone but that at its core really
has this idea that there's good and bad
emotions and so you start looking at the
just frightening you know public health
crisis which is that depression is now
the leading cause of disability globally
right it's crazy
stripping cancer insane heart disease
and so I think that what starts to
happen is we start um almost creating a
situation where we aren't able to
process difficult emotions when we in a
society that tells us positive thinking
is all that matters or positive emotions
all that matter and so we we actually
don't we don't develop skill sets around
us and so I you know the core ideas
behind emotional agility is this idea
that in order to navigate the world as
it is not as we wish it to be we need to
be able to strengthen our capability
with the full range of this beautiful
may see difficult human experience right
right right
in a culture in which we're actively
encouraged to go out it you know go out
of our way to avoid all of these
unpleasant emotions and if you should
find yourself in the grips of them you
should be ashamed for yourself you know
and whether it's a simple as security
and safety and luxury and comfort and
all that and and be
you know squarely within your comfort
zone or just you know the the sort of
daily emotions that we all experience on
some level along the spectrum of guilt
shame fear and and even just our
language which we often again it's with
with good intentions a friend of mine
recently died of breast cancer and she
said to me you know we were talking
about this tyranny of positivity and she
said to me it's so difficult because
when you when you have cancer and when
that cancer is terminal every person you
come into contact with tells you to just
stay positive just stay positive and
what she described is that it took her
away from actually being able to have
the authentic meaningful end-of-life
conversations that she needed to have
that even in her dying she was living
and she was able to and wanted to be
able to be able to have real
conversations with people that she loved
but it becomes very difficult when you
try to have those conversations and
people are like are you being negative
or you or you know you're not gonna beat
this cancer it says more about the
discomfort of the person delivering that
because it is so uncomfortable for most
people to talk about death and these
things are scary so when they they may
be well intentioned saying stay positive
but probably most likely they're
uncomfortable with anything other than
that right so so it's their way of like
well I have to say something great it's
that you know I'm not yet you know but
it's it's a band-aid for the person
who's delivering that rather than
actually being fundamentally mmm hopeful
so often I'm not saying you know there
might be many people in the world who
experiencing illness with someone saying
stay positive is helpful mm-hmm but I
know that they're there many people that
I've spoken to who find that it feels
like okay now not only do I need to beat
my cancer but I've now got to deal
wilfy somehow bad fourths that I'm not
allowed to be having right and and hold
up this face of strength when you don't
feel like it and and feel badly if you
can't live up to that you know kind of
inside of that also is this idea that
you explore which is that the more we do
actively deny these emotional states the
more we empower them like below the
surface the more we try to pretend
they're not there the stronger they
become they're doing push-ups in the
dark well it's so fascinating so gay and
I just want to stress that I'm not empty
happiness or like empty being positive
what I'm auntie is uh what I meant he is
a narrative that constructs good and bad
around these things and then leads us
into stages of expectation that I should
be happy or that I can't be unhappy and
yet it's fascinating when you look at
when you look for instance at people who
have a very strong expectation that they
need to be happy and you track those
people over time those people become
less happy that there's this when you
when you hold this idea that happiness
is more important than meaning as more
important than purpose is one then what
it is is it sets up some kind of goal
that is fundamentally unattainable and
so people who's actively strive to be
happy
become less happier over time what it
also does is it leads to greater levels
of in the book I talk about different
ways of dealing with emotion that are
difficult and one way is bottling our
emotions will be pushed aside difficult
emotions the others brooding where we
dwell on and what's fascinating is when
you bottle emotions when you push aside
difficult emotions there's this there's
this effect that's that's an
amplification or rebound effect that
these emotions actually come back
stronger and more and people have
experienced this if you you know again
are on a diet and you try not to think
of chocolate cake we know that you start
dreaming of chocolate cake when you ask
people to not think a particular thought
and you time them for a minute most
people will have that thought that's
been banned
40 times within that minute
so this idea of trying to push aside
suppress move away from these difficult
thoughts and feelings it just doesn't
work right allow yourself to feel them
as part and parcel of being human but
also understand that thoughts are just
things and emotions are just things and
you know one of the kind of tools or
lessons that I've learned in sobriety is
you know addicts and alcoholics drink
because they don't want to feed they
want to change their emotional state
they don't want to feel however however
unconscious that decision is it's a
decision to try to not feel however they
feel right and and sobriety is about
understanding and learning and embracing
the fact that these emotions although
they may feel like they're going to kill
you they're just emotions they have the
power that we attach to them and if we
can allow ourselves to just be okay
feeling them there is one thing that is
certain and that ultimately they will
shift and pass absolutely absolutely the
radical acceptance of our emotions even
the difficult ones is the cornerstone
but it's so scary it's scary it's scary
and and this is again when you parenting
we're helping your children very young
to start labeling their emotions not
trying to rush in and save your children
from difficult emotions because when you
save them from difficult emotions they
don't learn oh I was feeling sad 15
minutes ago and that emotion has now
passed mm-hmm I mean my happiness has
not derived from getting the next thing
or me you know and I wrote about this in
his book I said that somewhere along the
line I realized that having a lot of
[ __ ] ain't what brings you happiness
because I never had nothing and I've
given what I didn't make when I had it I
gave it away and my mom she couldn't
understand when I took a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars that I had saved
up and opened up the yoga center and
then maintained it for ten years you
know spending probably close to half a
mil I Q cousin aunt like it was robbery
right yeah I didn't get anything as a
matter of fact I did the construction
into place to on at 90
three st. marks and then I just turned
over the key and I was kind of like the
protector of the place making sure
nobody came there and [ __ ] with it or
did anything what's known as like the
temple commander I just made sure nobody
[ __ ] around and did anything stupid
and when people came in there and
misbehaved they got a warning and then
the next time it's like alright
[ __ ]
but the point is my mother was like you
could have had a house you could have
had and I'm like mom this is what I want
you to do I want you to come to the
sunday feast and I want you to meet the
people that this place is helping and
the family that we've developed with the
community and all these beautiful people
that had gotten off drugs and and and
overcome horrible [ __ ] by doing what I
did with the bhakti-yoga and this is the
place that they're they're learning it
and they're healing so she came to the
Sunday feast and she's like now I
understand she was like this is the most
[ __ ] beautiful thing that these
people you know are changing their lives
you're helping so many people and I'm
like you know there's a lot of people
living in big mansions man and they're
miserable people and they have no love
and and the Friends of a rockier there's
a lot of them around here and we passed
some places but you know everyone's
sponging off them and they don't know
who to trust the day after my money it's
like if you're my friend I know you're
my friend cuz you're my friend I ain't
got [ __ ] to give you only you think I
could give you is my time and and my
service and try to help you you're not
my friend cuz you could get something
from me materialistically
that's I don't have that to offer and
you know I you know when it comes it
comes I'm not attached to it either way
the bhagavad-gita says you have the
right to the work you don't have the
right to the results of the work that's
not what you're supposed to concentrate
and meditate on but the happiness of the
service that I've done over over since I
learned about it in 81 and started my
journey I wouldn't trade it for the
[ __ ] world if you said to me yo you
go back and I'm gonna give you [ __ ]
ten million dollars I wouldn't take it
and that's the God's honest truth
I've turned down TV shows and all kinds
of [ __ ] cuz it's not along the lines of
my core values and what what I see as
important so my happiness is not derived
from you know it's not from service that
in what's interesting is that that
that's very punk rock it is it's not
selling out yeah you're not supposed to
sell out that's the ethics of punk rock
but too many [ __ ] did sell out
everybody could talk to talk but guess
what what is maquis a true characters
revealed under pressure and when that
money came dangling in front of people's
faces you saw a lot of people change and
take off one uniform and put on another
this ain't a [ __ ] uniform for
me that's why even back in the day I
said this ain't about fashion and
clothes and how you look some of the
most punk rock [ __ ] I ever met
don't look like a punk rocker punk rock
is a spirit man it's a [ __ ]
consciousness it's like [ __ ] the man
it's about us the people and how do we
help people you know you can't just and
that's one of the things I always said
about punk rock I'm like it ain't enough
to just [ __ ] complain about something
and [ __ ] about it how do we fix it and
that's where that's not punk rock but
punk rock is more like Anarchy like blow
it up right they're not big on solution
yeah well that was what I was finding
but then I was seeing people like the
Bad Brains and crass who started organic
plant based communities and [ __ ] this
and that and like you started hearing
about other people in Krissy high and
was she into and she's into Vedic stuff
and and all these different people and
even the guy from the damn captain
sensible was vegan and like all it is
he's you saw an underlying spirituality
in the in the punk rock movement and a
lot of people in the movement like I
said when I was getting down with this
[ __ ] in 81 82 it wasn't too many aware
of conscious punk rockers
a lot of them [ __ ] laughs that
I stopped eating meat and that I would
go to the Krishna temple and meditate
and go do yoga or what do you I mean
they would say to my face well there's a
straightedge you know move now with him
later that was later right that came
later and that was part of the whole
kind of judgmental they didn't they
didn't comment people on the same level
they came at people thinking they were
superior to everybody else and that's
why everybody hated that [ __ ]
movement and that's why everybody hated
the [ __ ] vegan movement because they
didn't come at a compassion a lot of
people just were like I have this
knowledge that makes me superior to you
I'm even gonna [ __ ] you know talk
down to you like I'm better than you and
I think that's changed a lot now because
more and more conscious people are
getting into this for the right reasons
like I said I see it as a positive thing
and a lot of those people's voices got
silenced as a matter of fact I've seen a
lot of them go back to eating meat and
and and and leaving punk rock and
straightedge and going back to do drugs
and all kinds of [ __ ] so when you get
into something for the wrong reasons
that's not going to sustain your values
and your desire will always be tested in
life whatever the [ __ ] you pick up and
decide to attach yourself to that's why
I don't put any of them labels on myself
I know what my ultimate service is it's
bhakti-yoga or two words that changed my
life and those words are remember
tomorrow when you have a split second
decision that you have to make or
whatever remember how that decision is
gonna make you feel tomorrow you want to
drop out of the marathon at Mile
eighteen fine how you gonna feel
tomorrow when someone says how'd you do
mmm you want to take off your shirt and
drink the Keele at the holiday party and
dance on the table and swing around and
be the life of the party that's amazing
at the party until tomorrow and you know
those two words if you really think
about it when you have a key decision or
or you're at a critical juncture in
something big how are you gonna feel
when you make this decision tomorrow and
it it comes to peer pressure with you
know decisions
drugs with whatever and that's really
those words have really impacted me you
know I'm gonna blow off the workout
today rich we went lates an hour and a
half you haven't worked out yet you know
it's already the afternoon how you gonna
feel tomorrow about they're gonna be
pissed
mm-hmm right so that's a powerful thing
and any technique or tool or thing that
you can give yourself to give you an
edge and help you be better is amazing
and from me those techniques come
through trial and error trying a bunch
of different things and it's not some
expert telling me what to do yeah maybe
I'll try it but I have to convince
myself that it works you know and that's
been something those words have been two
words that really have worked for me mmm
powerful dude does that make sense yeah
it makes sense I think I think make
sense for me I think what you have to do
is you got it yeah it's like you said
you got to find the strategy that works
for you there's a million ways to do it
you can canvass you know that successful
people and they're all gonna tell you
you know a different approach to how
they do what they do and so when you you
know like read a book or listen to a
podcast it's like here's the morning
routines of the most successful people
well that's great you know like but
they're different right what works for
you what resonates with you that does
come through trial and error and you've
got to find your own groove like you
keep talking about like oh this Lane
that I'm in it's like you got to find
your lane without question the only way
you find that Lane is by trying out a
million hats if someone with a lot of
charisma tells you this is what he he or
she does they might be able to pull it
off because they have a lot of charisma
but if you're introverted it's gonna be
very difficult to follow that advice so
well not only that like if you're like
well Richard Branson does this in the
morning the idea that if you mimic what
Richard Branson does in the morning that
you're going to become put your Branson
is ridiculous and I feel like there's a
lot of disingenuous kind of snake oil
out there absolutes around selling these
kinds of ideas rather than on getting
people to do the inside work to really
figure out what makes them tick
activate you know that that sense of
self that will ultimately be the most
powerful guiding force you know to set
you on the trajectory that you're meant
to be on now that's powerful and you're
right it's what makes you tick
it's the thing that I can say I
everything was worth it all the work was
worth it
you know you dream of it and you put in
the hours you put in the time again
there's no there's no guarantee
everybody works hard but you believe in
yourself and you buy into this idea
every time you line up for a major I
mean again there's been twice where I
thought not I'm not gonna happen for me
this time but since 2011 moving forward
if I start a marathon it's I'm there to
try and win like I believe I can win
I've been preparing the last three
months and saying well um I'm going to
be a Boston Marathon champion so what
does the champion do when you bring that
attitude to every day you act as if
you're already there and then if it
doesn't happen you have to deal with the
aftermath and regroup and then buy into
yourself again and keep doing that and
not give up hope and so it's a really
hard thing to do and there's no
guarantees but yeah it makes all of that
worth it hmm yeah I think if there's
anything if there's like a word that
that really kind of captures your your
career it's just it's persistence right
you've got this phrase keep showing up
right you trademarked it just genius in
the works and you I have my computer
here because I wanted to read this tweet
that you had that you would pin which is
you posted this on March 5th some days
it just flows and I feel like I'm born
to do this other days it feels like I'm
trudging through hell every day I make
the choice to show up and see what I've
got and try to be better my advice keep
showing up so can you expound on that a
little bit because I think that's that's
applicable to anyone and everyone who's
chasing a goal or a dream yeah yeah I
mean the last 10 months prior to
this were really tough and it was as
simple as go out for a run and don't
skip the job just because you think it
might go a certain way or you don't feel
good just go and see and most of the
time you get out the door and it goes
better than you thought but if you don't
do it at all
like you have no chance of getting
better it's a zero it's you just look at
it with some kind of regret you know so
there was a lot of days where I didn't
want to get out the door in the past
couple months and it was just show up
just try just see and every time I've
done that you know it's the thing we say
there's no one comes back from Iran and
says I wish I hadn't done that right you
know and so for me it was just give
yourself a chance just try just start
and it's not always gonna go your way
but you don't know unless you show up
mm-hmm and is that something that that
you apply in other areas of your life I
tried to yeah I mean you know as a
friend and as a wife and all of that
even personal relationships it's just be
there for people you know try and be a
good wife and some days it's hard but
you show up and you do the best you can
and that's how you get better that's how
you learn and it's okay to fail just try
again the next day mm-hmm what is your
relationship with failure or how do you
think about failure yeah I actually
incredibly comfortable with it I talk
about it quite often last year was the
big thing I was like I'm you know trying
to win the Boston Marathon I put it out
there very publicly afterwards it didn't
happen I said you know I failed but
that's okay and people like you didn't
fail you were amazing this and that I
was like no it's like I wanted to do
this thing and I failed to do it that's
I failed but you don't failure is an
action it's not an identity we do it all
the time and if you learn from it you
get better and that's how you grow so I
think being super afraid of failure um
you kind of miss the point like those
are the lessons that's where you learn
the most like you fail your way to
success it may be that you get cancer
when you're 55 and that
was due to the fact that your immune
system is not working as well as it
could have because you brought in
deficient or you b12 deficient or your
vitamin D deficient or your folic acid
efficient so it's very important to to
say let me avoid the malnourishment
without interfering or with the with
beneficial effects so yeah without
needing to go into an area that where
the the protein becomes detriment mm-hmm
yeah my protein needs on that equation
of you know 0.32 comes out to about
between 60 and 70 grams a day it's just
it's not that hard like I some almond
butter I you know rice and beans I eat
lentils and quinoa and things like that
as long as I'm just eating those foods
like I've done the math and it seems to
it it almost takes care of itself like
if I'm just eating clean plant-based
foods close to the natural state so it's
not about going out of my way to make
sure I'm eating you know tons of carbons
of beans or anything no no no I mean I
do that fight that fight is a weakness
and so my diet is plant-based I this
week there's no problem but I do pay
attention I know yeah there's a certain
amount of certain vegetable contains so
much protein or so and so once you get
used that you know to check anything so
it's very straightforward I'm just
saying that I suspect when they compare
I say the vegans against the non vegans
and they saw that the vegans are not
doing better in those studies I suspect
that's because so many people in the
vegan group are malnourished and that's
why you see this otherwise III think the
vegans should've been doing much much
better than the non vegans if it wasn't
for my nourishment so if you could turn
the vegans into well nourished vegan
then I think we'll see the superiority
that we already see in the Blue Zones
and in Loma Linda etc yeah I think
that's astute I'm een I think my fear
and I think it's a very real fear is
that as we continue to produce all of
these processed versions of meat and
dairy products that are tasting better
and better and better that people that
are entering into you know becoming
vegan can easily just be eating all
sorts of refined grains all the time and
cookies and snacks and things like that
and they're you know they're like hey
I'm being and it's healthy when in fact
it perhaps might even be worse than
whatever they were doing before yes
absolutely so I think that this is why I
talk about you know once you figure out
what the science and all these pillars
are saying go back to your grandparents
table and among the healthy things pick
the ones that were coming at their table
know and so if you do that then I think
you're guaranteed especially if you go
with the grandparents or
great-grandparents that you're gonna
eliminate a lot of these this new
processed foods that you're talking
about so I mean I don't think there are
many - too many grandparents that ate
you know processed food you know in the
past so right there's been much much ado
lately about the relationship between
chronic inflammation and the onset of so
many of these lifestyle illnesses that
we're seeing I'm interested in your
perspective on that and what the
relationship is between inflammation and
aging yes that's a little tricky I think
it's clearly there there is no doubt
that in the brain and a lot of lots of
people in the Western countries or have
high inflammation inflammatory markers
to me is more of a consequence of
dysfunction than the cause of this
function so I think that the body the
liver is not working well so you start
making C reactive protein as a as a way
to respond to a dysfunctional state and
this is why we developed the fasting
mimicking diet and the idea was to you
know we can't change everybody's habits
but can we for example go after the
inflammation not just during the diet
but in the couple of month or three
months after the diet so is it possible
to hit some somebody with a five-day
diet they will have long-term
consequences and the inflammatory State
but not just the inflammatory State but
certainly that is one way to I think
assess functionality of the entire
system
right okay so let's let's get into this
world of fast I mean when does it first
become evident to you that this
relationship between Cal caloric
restriction and the impact you know
biochemically a positive impacts
biochemically starts to percolate your
awareness and where do you go with that
yes so first of all a caloric
restriction which is what Walford was
doing which refers to eating as a 25% to
30% less all the time it doesn't work
right it doesn't work for some reason we
know some reason we don't know but even
in mice you know the original
observation were made a hundred years
ago and then it turns out that about a
third of the genetic backgrounds
benefited from calorie restriction a
third were had neutral effects and a
third had negative effects right so I
think the periodic fasting mimicking
died build on this success and failure
why it's a success affair success
because if you look at colors to the
people or monkeys it's obvious that the
positive effects are remarkable for
example in the monkeys they were color
stated the the control monkeys 60% of
them developed diabetes in the color see
the monkey zero in the cardiovascular
disease and cancer reduction by 50% phi0
which is in what kind of caloric
restriction this was just 25 percent
among kids right now if you look at the
lifespan not change very much right so
then what does it tell you it tells you
that obviously you could probably cure
many many diseases by doing the right
intervention but calorie restriction is
not the way to do it because it gives
you as many problems as it gives you
solutions and this is the in humans and
any any monkeys humans we don't know for
sure yet but if you look at people that
are cut restricted you know man the
records they should have BMI of nineteen
eighteen point five nineteen they look
like the really borderline anorexic and
you know and you have to wonder is this
sustainable - is it a compatible with a
lifespan of 110 probably not as it
wasn't for the monkeys so that's where
the
and you know back in the days I made the
observation if I completely starve
year bacteria or I completely starved
yeast they live longer and they live
stronger right so longer stronger
meaning that you you hit them with
toxins nothing they're very strong and
and both of them and you know if you
look at bacteria and yeast is a
eukaryote so they're being separated by
hundreds of millions of years so I
started thinking is it possible that you
could do this for every organism and
it's gonna make a stronger and
protective for a long period and that's
where a lot of this comes from and so
jumping I had twenty years then is the
mouse studies that we first did which
were you know what if you take a mouse
and you give this fast in making that
why is it a fast American diet is a you
know what I was talking earlier about
the nutrient determine what genes are
activated or not sighs so if you have a
certain composition low protein low
levels of certain amino acids and then
low sugar high carbohydrate but low
sugar and high fat but good fats right
all that you put it together then the
response of the system is just like if
you giving it water only fasting you
just give water and you heal for for
four days and then you put them back on
a bad diet a relatively bad diet this is
a vegan so for vegan days for the mice
and then you know ten days of
animal-based diet and then you keep
doing this twice a month now we show
that the mice live longer about eleven
percent longer but the remarkable part
is the cancers were reduced by almost 50
percent Wow and in the inflammatory
diseases were reduced by fifty percent
and this mice just their cognitive
abilities was was much improved right so
they just looked younger healthier so
they live longer younger and healthier
then we did the human clinical trial
with this prolong fasting mimicking diet
and we did three cycles once a month
five days again vegan five vegan days of
this low protein Lord Sugar hide good
fat diet and and then we give them 25
days of no recommendation go back and do
whatever it is that you always done
no exercise recommendation or food no
nutrition recommendation and then we
measure the effects after a week and
three months after the last cycle mm-hmm
and you know I think the the results
were remarkable
so lower cholesterol blood pressure
lower triglyceride lower fasting glucose
lower inflammation systemic inflammation
is measured by CRP and lower igf-1 which
we believe is that one of the key
markers risk factors were both aging in
cancer but the interesting thing this
happened much more power it was much
more powerful in people that had the
problem to begin with so if somebody
started from an ideal situation there
were a lot less changes then somebody
that started with high levels of this
yeah of course my dream would be to have
people have better knowledge of access
to and the ability to take care of the
foundational basis and that is sleep
well get out in the Sun drink good water
eat a bunch of plants move your body
eliminate modern-day stressors of toxic
loads EMF stuff that's real it's not
hokey-pokey
it's real stuff affecting us in the
worst condition take medication from a
qualified I would say functional
medicine doctor who understands
nutritionally and biochemically and and
then put yourself into positive
stressful situations that evoke the body
turning on kind of its natural instinct
of accomplishment of overcoming so I
think in all of those situations if you
do not have a foundation of
of those things it's like trying to push
a boulder uphill if I'm running around
it's very clear on the evidence and
water alone if kids don't drink water
and they go to school their test results
are in the toilet I forget the exact
stat but it's like a 30 percent lead
that yeah impact of water on yeah
scholastic performance Oh huge and I
have some of my book I forget the exact
but it was like a few out like a glass
of water increase their performance by
20 or 30 percent really yeah the
hydration bro is like so destructive
that and the reptilian brain won't even
allow you to think of the thirst because
you have seven to ten percent of
Americans not even drinking an ounce of
water a day they're just going to their
coffee and existing and living on
adrenaline that is their up and go
molecule in their body that was only
meant to get away from a lion but
they're living on it 24/7
you are frying your hormonal system
you're frying your central nervous
system ie brain and we we expect to then
respond to this modern-day overachieving
situation when your basic and also the
other thing I said is proper breathing
right it what I didn't say is your basic
needs of your going against your basic
physiological need so when when at the
root of autism they've found dehydration
lack of nutrition these kinds of
situations so I always look at which is
why I didn't write a superfood book I
wrote a super life book about
foundational stuff because I told the
publisher I don't want to write it on
superfoods because I don't want to be
put in a thing like this is going to
cure you or take you away no I want you
Tom
understand that there's foundational
things that you can do that 99% of the
people on the planet are gonna thrive in
if you take care of that so all of these
other things and even medications are
like showing up to a forest fire with a
little squirt gun so originally I was
one of those people thinking that you
know you had to consume more protein and
now would equate to more muscle more
gains then I realized that you know
everything I read from like a clinical
study point of view not necessarily
bodybuilding.com nothing against them
they had a lot of great information I'll
read from like a lot of other
influencers or bodybuilders they go with
like the more as better approach so you
know 2 grams 2 to 3 grams sometimes
every pound of every pound of weight so
if I was 180 pounds I would need 360
grams of protein you know at least so
that's a lot Pettyfer vegan that's a
that's a lot a lot because you know to
get that much protein through plants you
got to eat a lot of volume so I started
looking at it and just like it didn't
make sense to me I was like everything I
read said like there was like an optimal
point and anything above that didn't
really work to your benefit you know you
might have extra calories but your body
kind of just like urinates the extra
nitrogen and you can't really use it
like there's a limiting factor there so
I go by lean body mass so just because
somebody's 200 pounds doesn't need you
don't need to consider them 200 pounds
of muscle you know we have body fat so
you don't need to feed the body fat you
can feed the muscle so I always go by I
calculate my lean body mass which is
your total mass minus your body fat
percentage so if I weighed 200 pounds
and I was 10 percent body fat then I
would my lean body mass would be 180 I'm
your lady grandmother so then there's
even another fraction that is like 0.8
to 0.9 times that and that's a number
that I go by right which is that's
really the like USDA recommendation
right or it's it's like point seven
grams per kilogram I think is what they
recommend yeah yes
I'm not sure exactly what it or what it
translates to in kilograms I always go
by pounds right I weigh a hundred and
eighty pounds right now
I keep my protein at like a hundred and
fifty grams uh-huh whether I'm bulking
shredding 150 still long maybe yeah
maybe a hundred and like sixty like
somewhere around there so that's a
typical bodybuilder is taking in about
twice that yeah no I'm more than twice
that because I go by lean body mass so a
lot of people calculate it by just total
mass huh and how did you arrive at that
and why have you decided that that's
what's optimal for you so there's
there's a clinical study out there that
references I don't know the reference
the exact reference but there's quite a
few out there that show that you know
after a certain point it doesn't benefit
you anymore
so I figured why not like find out where
that like I'll use that as a reference
and just kind of find out what works
best for me so like I said I do like a
lot of data analysis tracking and
optimization so there's like certain
body scans you can do to track like how
much your total mass is and how much of
that is muscle mass so when you're in a
deficit like a caloric deficit trying to
lead up to a show means you have to eat
less than what your maintance calories
are so you're gonna lose weight so you
want to do that as optimal as possible
because you don't want to sacrifice the
hard-earned muscle that you just spent
the offseason trying to gain so it
doesn't make sense to build up two
pounds of muscle just to lose two pounds
of muscle before a show so there's
there's a balance point there that you
have to kind of hover around and like
different scans like DEXA scans will
tell you how much muscle mass you have
in body scans measures like resistance
muscle impedance or impedance and will
translate that to how much muscle mass
you have on your body what your bone
density is so I track that and basically
if I'm losing more muscle than what I
want as I'm cutting down for a show I'll
kind of like increase my my protein a
little bit because that's not the goal
like I want to maintain that muscle and
like hold on to it and lose the body fat
so I just kind of use that it's kind of
like nutrition is different for
everybody I can tell you exactly my
number somebody out there can go follow
it they won't see the same results
because everybody responds differently
so that's kind of where I just use you
know trial and error right gotcha and
what is
the relationship between sourcing your
protein from Whole Foods vs. supplements
supplements are always gonna be a little
bit more processed so different doctors
out there T Colin Campbell for one of
them will tell you that you know when
it's more processed and isolated in its
isolated form your body doesn't
necessarily absorb it as efficiently so
it's always better to get the whole food
source because it contains other
chemicals that will help your body
absorb that that vitamin or mineral or
whatever so that's kind of where it led
me to maybe I'll just go more whole food
plant-based and see if if I see a
difference and it's the same so I just
kind of shifted all my like like more
alternative meat style of nutrition to
more whole food plant-based so that just
means that I have to eat more carbs more
beans more lentils all this stuff and I
love eating a little bit more tofu and
tempeh which I love as well and machine
same results right and you're in a sport
that is terrified of carbs yeah so
what's the with the relationship to
carbs and how do you you know think
about the the low carb no carb craze and
you know how there's a lot of talk about
ketogenic diets and all different kinds
of new ways of avoiding carbohydrates in
your diet as a means of optimizing
performance yeah I mean just from like a
basic nutrition point of view like carbs
or our energy source right so it doesn't
really make sense to cut those all out
there are times when you can manipulate
carbs to your advantage but you don't
have to like you don't have to cut out
carbs like very much so people in the
fitness industry or carbo phobic so they
refuse it's like anything that says
carbs in it they're like now I can't
touch it and anything has protein in it
they're like I'll give me more so my
approach is like first like optimize how
much protein you need right figure that
out first most people don't even have
any clue and so where does the 30 100
come into play like how is that birthed
you know I think spiritual teachers
develop vessels for consciousness
in the sense that I think if he tried to
start obviously if he tried to start a
3100 mile race in 1976 when the marathon
was love it you know
you bothered that what it would look
like somebody would have checked him
into some type of facility but after the
six-day race it became a ten day race
not to the ten day race it became a
seven hundred thousand and thirteen
hundred mile race and people were doing
really really well at that and by 1996
he decided to almost double the 1300 and
make it 2700 and people did it you know
there was a one woman in three men that
did it and then in 1997 he said okay
this is the distance I'm not gonna go
beyond it it's thirty one hundred right
thirty one hundred miles
this race has taken place every year
since ninety what is it nineteen ninety
seven ninety seven and this is a race
that entails running thirty one hundred
miles within a period of 50 50 to 52
days which means each runner is gonna
have to complete on average about 60
miles a day the kicker is the course is
essentially a half mile loop around the
high school in Queens on sidewalk in the
summer yeah it's ridiculous
it is absolutely insane and I'd heard
whispers of this race over the years and
I think I just filed it away in my brain
as apocryphal like I thought well this
can't actually be occurring in New York
City because you don't really hear about
it it doesn't get any press and what was
so amazing about seeing it in your movie
is that this occurs without really any
fanfare whatsoever there's how many
there were twelve people that that did
it and that that were documented what
was it last year that that you followed
these individuals yeah 2016 there were
12 participants and they just spend
their summer running around in a circle
they alternate the direction every other
day or something like that there's a
couple buses and campers parked out on
the sidewalk and you know some
volunteers there to hand out food
and write down their company laughs
they've done everyday the course is open
from 6:00 a.m. to midnight and it just
goes on until it's done and when it's
finished they're like okay you did it
and then it's essentially that's it it's
mind boggling you know I lived in that
area since 1997 and I frankly was
frightened of that race I'd run by it
it's unlike my one-mile point on my mind
wouldn't even talk about the fact that
you're a runner like you came from a
competitive running background but that
distance just frightened every single
pore of my body you know I didn't
understand how or why anybody would want
to do that and after you know I guess a
career in human rights and when I
started getting into film I started
wondering why a film hadn't been made on
that race of course it would be the most
boring film of the world if any film was
just about people going in circles but I
was encouraged to do a six-day race you
know to try to feel what people might
possibly get out of a 30 100 miles that
when you were kind of contemplating the
idea of trying to find a way in and make
a movie about this this event you know
it was even more elementary than that I
I need before trying to make a movie I
needed to understand like why to make a
movie you know what could possibly
appeal to an on 30 100 mile run er about
this race like why would anybody want to
do might want to watch a movie about
something that's so beyond what we might
even want to consider doing and so I did
a six-day race on the same course that
Fred Lebow
had started in 1986 and I didn't really
train much the interesting thing about
ultras is that you know you see people
from 18 to 70 years old doing ultras and
particularly since a lot of older people
do ultras I went in without much
training thinking like if a 70 year old
could do it like why couldn't I you know
I did about 50 miles the first six hours
then I got injured it's like I felt my
hamstring 20 50 miles in 6 hours that's
pretty good you know I think I didn't
know what to do I didn't know I didn't
know how to approach it but then I felt
my hamstring
twinge and as it twinged a few 75 year
old ladies walked by me and asked me how
I was doing and that's what I realized I
can't go hit you know it's like if these
women are doing this race and also the
nature of how you approach and conquer
an event like that is very different
than the mindset you know of the typical
runner or whatever your background in
and running experience was and so that
the next four days actually the next
four and a half days I was out on the
course 18 hours and I was barely doing
32 miles
I had a pulled hamstring mm-hmm and all
I could do in those four and a half days
was pray pray that I would get to run
again in the race you know I was never
more conscious of like my my frailty
then having 75 year old men and women
chatting with you and then apologizing
saying you're slowing me down and then
moving beyond but I would say almost
miraculously and without hyperbole what
the day left my hamstring felt normal
that just in an instant felt it felt
normal and then I took off it's like I
channeled I'd held like five almost five
full days of Prayer in my heart and when
that prayer had been answered I took off
and for the next about 21 hours I was
honestly in the highest meditation I'd
ever been in and you know it's like we
all say that like people sometimes they
like it when I chop onions it's
meditative and I don't mean like
repetitive I don't mean that my mind was
turned off I mean that every single
spiritual pore of my being felt like it
was about to have the biggest awakening
my imagination felt like reality you
know I was like feeling Hanuman I was
feeling like every Indian mythological
story I'd ever read I was feeling the
presence of those beings on that course
and no matter what I did whether I
stopped to eat
I stopped to fix my shoes as soon as I
start running again those experiences
came to the fore you were having a
transcendent experience I was so what do
you make of that you know when I talked
to runners after that who did the 3100
they said this is why we do it and I
said does it does that experience happen
in minute one they said no but after
four or five or six days regardless of
injuries like I had in the six-day race
after four or five or six days they find
that their mind shuts off finally
surrenders to the inevitable fact that
they would have to be running for the
next you know 52 days and the heart
comes to the fore in some cases the soul
comes to the fore and they get
experiences that are extremely
challenging to get through silent
meditation alone after the six-day race
I realized that there was a movie to be
made if I could capture that spiritual
essence of ultra distance running it you
know it might it might be of some
service I wanted to explore traditional
practices of running and of course
people who've read Born to Run know
about the Roar Amaury the Tarahumara
Indians that are connected culturally to
the Indians in the southwest of the
United States so I went to Santa Fe to
meet a friend who ran an organization
called the wings of America which really
focuses on Native American running
culture and revitalizing that I met one
of the board members who is an ultra
distance runner on the Navajo Nation and
when I wanted a morning run with him I
realized that his attitude towards
running was totally different than mine
I started my watch you know I was
looking for the GPS signal it's like
this is gonna be a great straw a run
through the canyon and it was a canyon
that people who weren't natives weren't
allowed to run in but we had permission
to run in it it sounds like I'm gonna
get some course records all this stupid
stuff but like you know technology and
my competition you know kind of you know
for me to believe but he was running for
different reasons the Navajo run towards
the east in the morning because that's
where the Rising Sun is and I could tell
that this fellow Shawn Martin whose
athletic director in Chile High School
in Arizona
he was receptive to the idea that this
run this regular morning run would make
him a better person it could also give
him an exceptionally spiritual
experience
and that was his attitude for money and
that had been baked in through 32 years
of cultural training on how to run and
so that's when I realized like most
spiritual teachers say like suffering
isn't the only path to enlightenment and
I think it's the same in running it's
like suffering isn't the only path to
the ultimate running experience Carl
Lewis used to say the same thing he used
to be so against that the idiom no pain
no gain you know there's there's
different attitude to approach sports
and I saw it in Sean Martin that day you
know the mission of charity water is to
bring clean water to people on earth and
that's a very clear mission mission is
accomplished when no human being on
earth is drinking dirty water but the
vision is actually much softer it's it's
it's some of the things you just said
it's to to bring people back to the true
meaning of charity charity means love it
means to look after your neighbor in
need and get nothing in return and I was
so upset that that word that this it's
become tainted for so many people in
charity is a bad thing not a good thing
like we need more love in this world I
mean look around yeah right we need more
people agreeing to agree on serving
others on ending needless suffering of
using our time in our talent and our
money to to help people to improve the
world and I just thought that the way
most people most charities approach this
was wrong like you said it was shame it
was guilt it was you you have too much
you know you should even even that the
language giving back I loathe this
language giving back you hear everywhere
it's in the lexicon now right oh I'm
giving back our companies giving back
that makes it sound like we have
pillaged and plundered to such extent
that we should finally throw a few
scraps down to the poor let's give a
little bit back so it's not something
you know if I take your phone out of
your hand you're gonna say give it back
right right why don't we drop the back
we should just we should frame giving in
the positive we are just giving what's
build a culture of giving in our family
in our company maybe in our faith
community let's give because we can
because we want to be
as its it's a blessing not out of
opportunity or sorry not out of you know
guilt or shame or debt or obligation but
because it is a an amazing opportunity
to share our blessing with others and I
actually would love to get people
addicted to giving you know it's funny
my my my ambition right now around money
and I'm 43 I've got you know beautiful
wife and two kids but my ambition around
money is to give more away is to
personally give more away yeah someone
and I write about this someone many
years ago wrote a million-dollar check
that changed the game for charity water
it was an inflection point and it took
us from the brink of insolvency because
we had me down last time yeah we had I
want to do that for somebody else yeah
like I just have this dream of one day I
don't know how I'm gonna do it on a
charity salary but one day I would love
to walk into someone else's office a
young social entrepreneur and not just
give them advice okay because I can give
a lot of people advice but I would like
to actually so that's the ambition not
the house in the Hamptons not the
Mercedes or the Tesla you know not the
vacation you know the Four Seasons and
that that's really true you know and in
some ways it's freeing because I'm I
don't feel trapped yeah I not have you
know the next like the minute I would
get the Tesla I'm sure I'd want a better
car you know or the minute I went on
that vacation well somebody went on an
even nicer vacation or stayed at the
nicer hotel in the island right so
there's it's been so freeing twelve
years ago to just step off of that rat
race and think about think about how I
can be useful I can be a vessel so many
people are living their lives feeling
incredibly disenfranchised they're
disconnected from the fruits of their
labor from anything that that that
provides them with passion you know
they're just trying to get through the
day and pay the bills and there's this
malaise the sense that one person really
can't make a difference like yeah I can
put a quarter in the in the little box
from whoever when I'm walking into
Walmart but like is that really doing
anything and
and and so I love how a big part of the
ethos of charity:water is is helping
people to really reframe that and to
really understand that one person can
make a difference a very tangible
impactful difference and with that comes
this sense of purpose that can overcome
one and in doing that you tell amazing
stories about you know everyone from the
girl with the lemonade stand to whoever
so I thought it would be nice if you
could tell one of those stories for
somebody who's listening to this who
feels ah yeah yeah I'm hearing
everything Scott saying but like you
know I don't know how I could have that
kind of feeling in my own life first let
me just yeah I know you haven't gotten
there yet
you basically just delivered the end of
the book so I'm gonna read the last
alright boom the last line you didn't
even know where I was gonna end but
that's it so it says you know it ad last
count charity:water is funded more than
28-thousand water projects that'll help
eight and a half million people get
clean water people who will never have
to experience what it was like before
the water ever again we still have so
much work to do yet every day I wake up
hopeful that we will solve this problem
in my lifetime I believe that together
we can bring life's most basic necessity
to the six hundred sixty three million
people who still don't have it I'm just
one guy who built one charity but it's
made a little dent in the water crisis
next year we'll make a bigger dent and
this is how the problems of the world
gets solved one by one by me and you and
us I really believe that beautiful like
as we you know as we all join our voice
together so I'll end on um my story it's
a new story it's not in the book we're
about to launch our big World Water Day
campaign March 22nd at the organization
we had a whole campaign lined up and
then somebody opening up the mail at HQ
gets a note little picture and eight
dollars and 15 cents and we learned it's
from a six-year-old named Nora and the
note says dear charity water
I saw your video and I'm sending in
eight dollars and 15 cents because I
want kids to stop bat dying a bad water
I wouldn't kid to stop dying a bad water
and she draws a picture of herself next
to a well in Africa what
you think said well looks like with the
clean water coming out so charity water
you know we're storytellers like stop
the presses
cancel the campaign let's see if Nora
will let us put her on camera and tell
her story so we have a camera crew down
in Virginia a week later and Nora opens
up her house a six-year-old girl and on
camera she's this precocious girl that
says well I saw the video and I went up
to my room that night and I just I ask
myself the question should I give my
money or should I keep my money
should I give my money should I keep my
and she's back in Portland it's so cute
to hear and she says so I came down in
the morning I said I would give my money
so she drops eight dollars and 15 cents
from her allowance and shemales it in
and ahh there's so much there right the
purity of heart and by the way we're all
asking ourselves a sex the same Russian
right should I guess should I not should
I trust should I not so she comes out on
the right side for her and we launched a
campaign around this three-minute video
and she's just she's beautiful she has
this heart to serve others and when you
see her on camera you just melt you're
like I want to be that pure I want to it
like the simplicity had it back to the
public you know Jesus it let little
children come to me right we will be led
by children the simplicity of children
to teach adults these these values of
generosity compassion and purity so we
just told her story and we asked
everyone just to give 8 dollars and 15
cents and how much was raised 80 grand
in a day so that's the SWAT unit wells
yeah and she so her seed her vision of
eight dollars and 15 cents
turned into a thousand times more uh-huh
and what does she think of all this she
loved it hopefully we'll get to take her
there yeah hopefully she can go and see
some of that impact one day we do think
about that like how do we close the loop
but I would hope that even Nora might
live her life a little differently that
that the feedback loop that seeing
people respond you know might even
encourage her to give up Chris being
that age and then suddenly your
the seed that that that germinates this
amazing flower that has to impact her
and make her think I mean it had to be
an amazing feeling for her but going
back to that sense of not educating the
emotional body think about these
depression has a value because when
you're depressed you can go into some
pretty deep places some pretty dark
places and when you go into those places
with the sense of let me explore rather
than you know let me feel horrible those
deep places can confine character
confined parts of your being that are
able to come forward there would never
be it noticed if you were just giddy and
happy all the time and the same thing
with good grief right grieving sadness
grief you know these are also valuable
moments but they're not moments that we
should use if we want to go back to the
idea of a of a diet we shouldn't use
them as entrees we should use them as
you know maybe spices or maybe you know
side dishes to the main the main course
the main course you know our focus on
becoming enthusiastic becoming inspired
becoming fulfilled that's our main
course with side courses that are you
know either warning signs or augmenting
components like salt salt augments the
food so depression and grief and sadness
are all things that when they come upon
us we should go into fully but giving
ourselves the space I'm gonna take a
sick day because I'm feeling really sad
and let me go into this sadness let me
process this sadness let me gain the
messaging from this
this just as if I was to take a sick day
because I've got the flu
yeah these emotional states are part of
what it means to be human - it was
embrace and accept the fact that it's
perfectly natural and fine to experience
sadness to experience grief to
experience intermittent bouts with
depression and it's all make a
correction here I don't ever do this but
rich what I'm just gonna make a
correction you said what it takes to be
human I saw the dog your dog be sad in a
moment because he couldn't come in here
oh he won't bring her in for round two
but yeah I mean where it goes back to
you know the the messages that we
receive about what's okay what's not
okay in this collective experience that
we're having and we're kind of taught
like you should love your life and be
happy and be enthusiastic all the time
and if you experienced a moment of
depression that you should actually
compound that by being ashamed we're
feeling bad about yourself because
you're experiencing something that you
feel like you shouldn't be experiencing
and of course that's it cross-purposes
with with our kind of wired right but I
think there is a difference between that
sine-wave of emotional experience that
we all have versus chronic states of
depression and and that's really kind of
what I'm focused on is this incredible
increase in persistent chronic states of
depression that people are experiencing
and whether that and you were saying
like that you disagreed with me about
what the the cause of that is but I want
to go a little bit I said I agree with
you
they're all about they're all that they
are the heart of the region but that the
cause was that were not prepared mm-hmm
think about chronic what about chronic
flu that you go through a winter and you
you get it you seem to be well you go
out and do something energetically
you get a relapse you get it you go
through it you seem to be well you go
out and do something energetically you
get a relapse
what's not happening what is not
happening is that there's not a full
forced cure so if I'm to go into my flu
or if I'm to go into my depression and I
can fully experience the experience as
the Buddha said anything fully
experienced any of the emotions fully
experienced will ultimately become its
base factor which is joy because going
in and I've been depressed we've all
been depressed the difference between
someone who has the awareness or the
knowledge when that depression comes on
is the same as when someone has the
awareness or the knowledge hmm you just
pass the frog when the flu comes on if
you can go into and fully work with that
flu germ and get it so that it's
completely removed from the body after
you've gone through the cycle it's the
same way with depression with sadness
with other things with grief etc think
about the grief of people dying I've had
three or four people just recently reach
out to me because they're someone very
very dear to them has passed away and
that idea of shame that you need to
grieve in private or that you should
wear dark glasses at a funeral so to
hide the tears that are rolling down
your face all of this is exactly what
you were saying that crossed purposes
that shame for sadness shame for
depression shame for grief is something
that we need to remove through education
we need to inform people that their
grief is good that their sadness is a
value and that their depression has some
message and just like the flu if you
give yourself the opportunity to go
through that cycle that you were just
mentioning then it won't become chronic
depression it will become deep
depression maybe even deeper than the
the cycles of chronic depression but it
will be fully experienced and then
relieved from the psycho emotional body
right so in other words what you're
saying is if somebody is experiencing a
depressive state that there is something
built into that like a teachable moment
something to be learned if you fully
embrace it if you just allow yourself to
get swallowed up in it I suppose for a
lack of a better word to really feel it
rather than resist it and try to kind of
surf the wave and learn what is trying
to be spoken to you through that
whatever message is trying to be
conveyed is is a trajectory out of it
right but I'm imagining somebody who
maybe is listening to this or watching
those who who is thinking I've had
chronic depression my whole life or I'm
a manic depressive or I've been battling
this since I was a child constantly in
pain you know I've tried to understand
I've done everything I've tried to do
everything and it's just this is how I'm
wired I need to be medicated for this
and and and feeling defensive at what
you're saying okay exceed up being
provocative for somebody who suffers and
so I would say that do not take my words
as being absolute or even that they're
my absolute perspective there are so
many contributing factors to sadness
grief depression and all of those
emotions and some of them are genetic
some of them are truly biological and
chemical
to be able to take medication is
important in today's world we have
evolved to have those kinds of
substances that we can take to help
balance out chemistry's but I would say
to the audience to just take the
medication is going to resolve symptom
but it's not necessarily going to
disrupt source and so what you want to
do is you know you don't want to be
overwhelmed by the symptom so you take
you continue to take your medication but
then you also add to it something that's
going to disrupt the source code of that
what you call wiring and that is there
are so many things available I mean just
the activities that you do you know the
bike rides the swims the runs the
activities that I do the yoga the
meditation will you also do those too
and these are all things the long walks
on the beach the conversations with
loved ones that other things that we can
do to help to rewire that that network
Jonathan Hite talks a lot about this in
his book righteous mind which was so
influential am I thinking I recommend
everybody read it but in in order to
have unity of any kind of nationalistic
unity you need a common enemy so the
more divided a country gets often it
means the more the more we bicker about
smaller and smaller things it's actually
like a it signifies a pretty healthy
society where you're freaking out over
little nuanced things happening in
government whereas like when you have a
common enemy like Pearl Harbor or Hitler
I mean that's why the greatest the
greatest generation rose out of the
world having a common enemy the Axis
powers and it's it created this entire
generation of Americans that felt
unified in
we are America we stand for virtue we
stand for valor we stand for democracy
against tyrants and you still see people
using that language in a generation like
mine where war is so bifurcated into
things that don't feel like war they
feel like response to terrorism they
feel like so provincial and strange and
alien and and complex and like why are
we even fighting this to where now you
know a lot of people my age see someone
in uniform and they have mixed emotions
about it they're not like wow what a
hero they're like wow what are you doing
over there you know and that really you
know the breakdown probably began with
Vietnam I wasn't alive but what I
perceive of history and so and we felt
it a little bit in my lifetime with 9/11
where America became America for like
six months or something and I remember
feeling that like I remember seeing an
American flag on like September 19th
2001 and thinking I love this country
and what we stand for and I want to kiss
everyone I see on the street because
there was this idea of having a common
enemy we're very complex apes who are a
tribe and our tribes have just continued
to expand so the more complex we get the
more difficult it will be to have unity
as a globalized world as a nation and so
you've all her re as he said on your
show thinks climate change could do that
but as you said it's so ephemeral it's
really hard to like hate a temperature
degree difference you know like what
does that even look like in terms of the
way in which we speak to each other and
the like complete falling apart of civil
discourse I think a lot of it has to do
with us reverting to these natural
instincts of creating enemies out of
those that disagree with us you the
moment you can like call a group of
people cockroaches you dehumanize them
and you know or deplorable or whatever
you want to say and you you create a
categorical stereotype that is now able
to be crushed
and I was listening to this interview of
Oprah by Van Jones the other day and Van
Jones asked her if you had ten minutes
alone with Donald Trump what would you
say to him and I loved her answer I'm
still thinking about her answer but she
said I don't know I don't really speak
to people if I won't I won't speak to
someone if I know I won't be heard
mm-hmm
and so I'd probably be silent or she
said something like that and I really
thought about if you can't be heard and
it is what happens when a liberal and a
conservative are shouting at each other
yeah nobody's listening no one's
listening I mean and that's actually
brain chemistry when you're in an
argument the part of your brain that
learned some information loses blood the
part of your brain that is the filing
cabinets of your own argument is raging
with neuron like firing and so you the
part of you that learns is turned off
the part of you the defense it's pre
held positions is on raging and so
heated arguments that's what that's why
nothing good has ever happened on
Twitter except being surprised by news
is like no one in a Twitter battle ever
reaches a new idea it's rare I'm sure
it's happened but so I think I think
there's places certainly important
places for people to be angry anger is
an expression of pain is an important
expression of pain and it gets attention
and draws attention to a cause and then
I think there's important places for
people who fly 30,000 feet above and say
let's understand where you're coming
from let's understand where you're
coming from and let's let let you both
reach a place of relative safety where
you can hear each other and so how do
you do that in a one-on-one I mean you
live you live in Silverlake but you you
go home like you're home all the time
right you're in Tennessee you're you're
you're you're part of that community
still back there oh yeah so when you are
engaging somebody you know one-on-one or
at a dinner party
you're with your mom what does that look
like if you do not have respect for the
person you're talking to and if you
cannot entertain the fact that you might
be wrong you cannot have civil discourse
it's it becomes charity at that point it
becomes patronizing it becomes
propaganda
I don't know that everything I believe
is true I believe certain things have
significant evidence and other things do
not
I've never seen a polar bear die from
global warming but I know a lot of
scientists agree that it's happening and
so I tend to trust experts I am a
progressive person I'm socially
progressive I've seen how progressive
policies have impacted my life as a gay
man and the life of my black friends the
life of my people who have people of
color in my life I've seen how
progressive policies have changed
history I've also seen how hyper
far-left policies have destroyed entire
nations and so fiscally conservative
people have a lot of good ideas I've and
I for me you can have a good
conversation with anyone if you're
curious about what they think and why
they think it and a lot of times people
have never asked them and so I tend to
remove myself I feel like a very small
ant on a very large planet and so
screaming at my cousin for voting for
Trump and believing that climate change
is not real feels like it's gonna give
me high blood pressure and I don't know
what's gonna change mm-hmm whereas if I
am curious about why he thinks that way
and then I make him feel safe and
respected he may be curious about why I
feel that way and I mean and I've had
conservative friends tell me you're the
only liberal person I can talk to
[Music]
you